su partido laborista guió a Nueva
Zelanda a través de una pandemia una
erupción volcánica y un atentado
terrorista pero seis años después es
hora de dar un paso al costado la
dimisión de yasim da arden tras dos
mandatos sorprendió a los nuevos
holandeses pero para ella presentarse a
un tercer periodo no es algo que esté
dispuesta a hacer
no me voy porque crea que no podemos
ganar las elecciones sino porque creo
que podemos y que lo haremos y
necesitamos un nuevo par de hombros para
ese reto
el único ángulo interesante que
encontrará es que después de pasar seis
años de algunos grandes desafíos Es que
soy humana los políticos son humanos
damos todo lo que podemos durante el
tiempo que podemos y luego es el momento
y para mí es el momento en 2017 ardron
accedió al cargo con 37 años
convirtiéndose en la jefa de gobierno
más joven del mundo en este momento en
2019 cuando apenas llevaba 18 meses en
el cargo un pistolero supremacista
blanco masacró a 51 personas en dos
mezquitas de chry storch tomó medidas
inmediatamente apoyó a la comunidad
musulmana de Nueva Zelanda prohibió el
uso de armas semiautomáticas en todo el
país e instó a las empresas tecnológicas
a frenar la promoción del extremismo
violento en internet
en los dos primeros años de la pandemia
arden de 42 años se convirtió en un
modelo para otros líderes mundiales por
su gestión de la crisis sanitaria
cerrando las fronteras del país lo que
provocó pocas muertes por el virus
Aunque Popular en el extranjero se
enfrentó a la creciente ira en casa de
los que se opusieron a las reglas y
normas por el covid Desatando protestas
antivacunas que acabaron en violentos
enfrentamientos con la policía el
gobierno de ardron fue criticado por no
cumplir su promesa de cerrar la brecha
de la desigualdad
su último año en el cargo también fue
testigo de una oleada de asaltos a
tiendas por todo el país
jacinda arder seguirá siendo diputada
hasta las elecciones generales del 14 de
octubre Pero espera que el partido elija
a su sustituto antes de que deje el
cargo el 7 de febrero